HEARING I APOLOGIZE FOR RUNNING
A LITTLE LATE THERE WAS A LITTLE
BIT OF A MIX UP AT THE AIRPORT.
BUT WE'RE HERE SO WITH THAT --
WILL CALL FOR THE ROLE I THINK
WE HAVE A FORM.
PORTANTINO I'M HERE PORTANTINO
HERE BATES.
BATES HERE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE HELL.
JONES JONES HERE WE CASKEY HERE
WE CASKEY HERE.
THANK YOU EVERYONE -- WE HAVE
TWENTY SIX BILLS TODAY FOUR OF
WHICH ARE ELIGIBLE WITH A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THE REMAINING BILLS ARE ALL
SUSPENSE ITEMS -- I'D LIKE TO
REITERATE OUR MESSAGE THE
AUDIENCE MEMBERS THAT TESTIMONY
SHOULD BE LIMITED TO THE FISCAL
IMPACTS.
OF THE BILL -- PLEASE REFRAIN
FROM RE LITIGATING THE POLICY
DISCUSSIONS A FEW -- WHAT THAT
WOULD BE APPRECIATED?
AND SERGEANTS -- THERE'S ANYBODY
NOT HERE PLEASE CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS I ALSO WANT TO
GIVE A SHOUT OUT I UNDERSTAND
OAKRIDGE HIGH SCHOOLS IN THE
HOUSE.
ARE THEY JUST WAVE YOUR HANDS
LIKE THAT.
LOOK AT THAT.
WE LIKE IT WHEN YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
ENGAGED IN GOVERNMENT I HAVE A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER SO
ALL PARENTS OF TEENAGERS GOD
BLESS YOU [inaudible]
AND THE INVITE YOU SURVIVE. FIVE
SURVIVED ONE I'M HOPING TO
SURVIVE THE OTHER -- SO AUTHORS
PRESENTING WE HAVE -- MISTER
BELL MISTER MCGUIRE MISTER WILL --
THEN I THINK MISS BATES YOU'RE
GONNA PRESENT FOR MR WELL YES IF
YOU.
OKAY AND THEN.
ALL RIGHT SO WITH THAT.
WE SHOULD START AT MISTER BELL
YOU HAVE.
SB TEN NSP TWELVE SP ONE NINETY
SEVEN SB TEN SB.
TWELVE R. SUSPENSE
RECOMMENDATIONS SB ONE NINETY
SEVEN IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION SO PLEASE COME UP --
OBVIOUSLY -- WE DO HAVE TWO OF
THE THREE ARE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES.
A UNIT TO AMEND BILL ORDER OR IF
IT'S YOUR PLEASURE THAT'S FINE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD TELL US BUT IT'S
BEEN.
TEN OKAY -- GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY HOPE YOU HAVE A GOOD
MONDAY -- TURN MEMBERS -- TODAY
I'M PRESENTING SB.
TEN A BILL THE STATUS IS A
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR PEER
SUPPORT SPECIALISTS.
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES. FORTY
EIGHT STATES HAVE ADOPTED THE
PEER CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS
MEANING THEY HAVE ESTABLISH THE
CLEAR BASIC STANDARDS FOR PER
TRAININGS.
NOW THE FOR FEDERAL CENTERS OF
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID RELEASE A
GUARDIANS TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVEN FOR STASHING.
A CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. FOR
PEERS TO ENABLE THE USE OF
FEDERAL MEDICAID FINANCIAL
PARTICIPATION.
WITH A 50% MATCH REDUCING THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN FOR STATE.
AND COUNTY PROVIDERS.
NOW OFTEN TIMES APPEARS SERVE AS
A FIRST SUSTAIN POINT OF CONTACT
FOR FOLKS LIVING WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS AND ASSIST THEM. FOR
TREATMENT.
THAT THEY NEED AT THE EARLIEST
MOMENT.
THE BILL WOULD DIVERT MORE FOLKS
FROM EMERGENCY SERVICES ENSURE
PATIENTS RECEIVE A CONTINUUM OF
CARE SAVING SUBSTANTIAL COSTS OF
TREATMENT -- IMPROVING HEALTH
OUTCOMES.
NOW FEES GENERATED THROUGH THE
PEER CERTIFICATION BY THE
DEPARTMENT WILL ALSO REDUCE THE
COST THE COST.
OF IMPLEMENTATION OF SB.
TEN AND I HAVE WITNESSES MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- I'LL TURN IT OVER MY
WHEN THIS IS NOW THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ADRIAN CHILTON WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE WE ARE THE
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF SB.
TEN WHICH OFFERS A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK TO
CERTIFY AND TRAIN APPEARS IN
CALIFORNIA'S MEDI CAL PROGRAM.
YOUR SUPPORT IS AN EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICE WITH A SPECIFIC
DEFINITION OF SERVICE THAT
OPERATES UNDER A SPECIFIC CODE
OF ETHICS.
THIS BILL IS REALLY PART OF A
GREATER EFFORT -- IN CALIFORNIA
TO TRANSFORM OUR MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM OF CARE FROM ONE THE
INTERVENES EARLIER WHEN OMEBODY
ASKED FOR SUPPORT OR SOMEBODY ON
THE OTHER END OFFERING THAT
SUPPORT.
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT COST BENEFIT
DATA ON PEER SUPPORT SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND ALAMEDA COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
APPEAR MENTORING PILOT PROJECT
THAT MATCH PEERS WITH
INDIVIDUALS OR LEASE FROM
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS.
FOUND A 72% REDUCTION AND RE
ADMISSIONS TO THE HOSPITAL TO
THE COST SAVINGS FOR ALAMEDA
COUNTY WAS OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS WITH AN INITIAL
INVESTMENT OF TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THIS WAS A FOUR HUNDRED AND 70%
RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
SO THERE ARE NATIONAL STUDIES AS
WELL -- BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT CLIENTS WHO RECEIVE PEER
SUPPORT SERVICES HAVE BETTER
HEALTH OUTCOMES REDUCING OUR
COSTS WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU. TWENTY MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS TOBY
DOING I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION.
THE COMMISSION ALSO IS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND IS CO
SPONSORING.
AS I THINK YOU KNOW THIS IS A
PERFECT IN THE NOW SAYS THE
STATE HAS TRIED TO MOVE IN THIS
DIRECTION A COUPLE OF TIMES.
FROM THE COMMISSION'S
PERSPECTIVE THIS IS A A STRAIGHT
FORWARD APPROACH TO ADDRESS A
COUPLE OF CHALLENGES WE HAVE
FIRST WORKFORCE CHALLENGES.
PEERS ARE AMONG THE LOWEST COST
HIGHEST IMPACT EMPLOYEES THAT WE
CAN HAVE AN OR MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
AND JUST AS IF AS WE'VE
RECOGNIZED THE RANGE OF
CHALLENGES WE HAVE IN ADDRESSING
OUR WORKFORCE ISSUES.
THIS BILL NEEDS TO BE PART OF
THE STATE'S STRATEGY TO REALLY
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE RIGHT
PEOPLE IN PLACE IN THE RIGHT
TIMES.
WHO CAN DELIVER CARE IN A VERY
COST EFFECTIVE MANNER?
THE STATE ALSO HAS BEEN
INVESTING. TO OUR S. P. EIGHTY
TO TRIAGE DOLLARS IN GRANTS TO
COUNTIES TO ACTUALLY PUT TEARS
IN PLACE IN HOSPITALS.
IN OUR TO TO PREVENT
INAPPROPRIATE E. R. UTILIZATION
IN OUR JAILS TO PREVENT
INAPPROPRIATE INCARCERATIONS
WE'RE ALSO USING PEERS AS PART
OF OUR UTREACH STRATEGY.
WITH THE BILL TRIES TO DO IS PUT
IN PLACE A SET OF STANDARDS
REFLECTIVE NATIONAL STANDARDS
AND PUT IN PLACE THE CAPACITY TO
DRIVE DOWN FEDERAL MONEY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S APPROPRIATE
COST SHARING BETWEEN THE STATE.
AND THE COUNTIES AND THE FED
THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS WE THINK
THIS BILL MAKES A TREMENDOUS
ECONOMIC SENSE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS WORK FOR
SENSE.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY IT IS ITS
SIGNALS HOW THE STATE IS WORKING
TO REDESIGN OUR MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS THAT WERE RESPONSIVE TO
THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE.
WHO NEED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
NOBODY BETTER THAN APPEAR
UNDERSTANDS WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH SOMEONE TO TAKE THEM A
CRISIS?
AND CAN HELP REDUCE THE IMPACT
OF THAT CRISIS ON THE INDIVIDUAL
AS WELL AS ON A BROADER MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM SO WITH THAT WE
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
LINE UP PLEASE REBEKAH GONZALEZ
NATIONALIST ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER.
A HIGH IT CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
MORNING TURN MEMBERS BRING STATE
YOUR LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS PROP COSPONSORS OF
THE BILL.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BY
CALVET WORK IN SUPPORT.
ROGER BENTLEY SCARS WERE IN
SUPPORT. ONE IS THE MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE CHRISTOPHER BARTON
MENTAL HEALTH BOARD SACRAMENTO
STRONG SUPPORT.
STAVING ON THANK FROM SCOTT'S
INTERNATIONAL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING COLECTIVOS APPEAR
AND COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT MANAGER
FROM CAL MAY SEND STRONG SUPPORT.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION AND FOR
THEIR SUPPORT -- FINANCE GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
STILL IN A TERROR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I HAVE NO
FILE IN THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER BELL -- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT WHEN THE SUSPENSIONS
LIFT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN
WILL GO TO SUSPEND SOMEONE MOVE
ON TO SB [inaudible]
TWELVE THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS -- NOW PERCENT S
TWELVE THIS IS A BILL AS HELL
ESTABLISHES INTEGRATED YOU'VE
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM -- IT
MINISTERED BY THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
THE GOAL OF THIS PROGRAM IS TO
SERVICES SERVICE OF YOU'VE DROP
IN MENTAL HEALTH CENTERS.
ARE TO PROVIDE PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES TO
YOUTH AGE -- TWELVE TO TWENTY
FIVE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE MERGING
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES HAVE
DIFFICULTY.
FINDING TIMELY APPROPRIATE
TREATMENT.
IN A SERVICE SYSTEM THAT CAN
RESPOND -- JUST -- AS AN
EVIDENCE -- THE RAPID RISE IN
SUICIDES AMONG USE -- IS A
CLASSIC EXAMPLE OF THE LACK OF
SERVICES. TWO THIRDS OF
ADOLESCENTS WITH MAJOR
DEPRESSIVE F. HAVE OF EPISODES
DID NOT GET TREATMENT AND LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
ARE EVEN LESS LIKELY -- BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF EARLY
IDENTIFICATION AND INTERVENTION
SERVICES YOUNG PEOPLE OFTEN DO
RIGHT REACH OUR HEALTH SOCIAL
SERVICE OR JUSTICE SYSTEMS.
INTEL THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS HAVE BECOME MORE SEVERE.
AND OFTEN MORE DIFFICULT AND
COSTLY TO TO TO TREAT.
THIS BILL A APPROACHES YOUTH
WELLNESS IN A COMPREHENSIVE AND
YOU FRIENDLY WAY.
LET LED BY MEMBERS OF AN ACTIVE
USE ADVISORY GROUP TO DESIGN THE
SERVICES.
ENVIRONMENT THEY MOST WANT TO
SEE IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
NOW THE OP MISTER CHAIRMAN THE
OPERATIONAL COST OF SANDERS --
WE ESTABLISH THIS -- BY THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY -- PILOT
MODEL.
AND IT'S APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
INCLUDING RENDON FELT STILL THE
RENOVATION COSTS.
AND IN COMMUNITIES WITH LOWER
REAL ESTATE VALUES IN.
SILICON VALLEY WHICH IS PROBABLY
YOUR HIGHEST IN.
YOU CAN PROCESS POSSIBLY FIND IN
THE WORLD -- THE OPERATIONAL
COSTS FOR THE CENTERS PROBABLY
WILL BE SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
SINCE THE INITIATION THIS
PROJECT IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
THERE'S BEEN A HIGH.
FILL AND TROPIC -- INTEREST IN
THE PRIVATE SET FROM THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
THE INTEREST IS UNIVERSAL
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THE CENTERS
ARE LOCATED -- WE HAVE A
STANFORD SEC SCHOOL OF
PSYCHIATRY.
PARTNERING WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT. TO
SUPPORTS.
THE CENTER ALSO BENEFITS.
IN FORM OF IN KIND SUPPORT.
FROM OTHER PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING LUCILLE PACKARD
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL -- WE HAVE
OUR CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
SUPPORTING [inaudible]
THIS PROGRAM.
THIS PROPOSAL CALLS FOR CLEAR
INCENTIVES FOR COUNTIES TO
LEVERAGE LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH AND
OTHER RESOURCES.
AND FEDERAL FUNDS WERE AVAILABLE.
AND INSURANCE REIMBURSEMENT HAVE
AS A STRATEGY TO MAXIMIZE THE
IMPACT OF THIS INVESTMENT --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- TURNED
OVER MY WESTON'S WITNESSES
MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER BELL WITNESSES
PLEASE.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M STEVE THAT'LL TIME
I'M GLAD TO BE HERE TODAY I'M A
CHILD PSYCHIATRIST BY TRAINING
IN THE DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER
FOR YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING
AND THE STANFORD DEPARTMENT OF
PSYCHIATRY -- WE'RE REALLY
PLEASED TO BE -- BRINGING THIS
EFFORT TO TODAY WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED AFTER I'VE BEEN
WORKING FOR MANY YEARS IN SCHOOL
MENTAL HEALTH AND IN EARLY
PSYCHOSIS WORK.
THAT THERE'S BEEN A REAL GAP IN
TERMS OF EARLY INTERVENTION
ACCESS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE REALLY
ALL OVER THE UNITED STATES AND
WITH THIS BILL AND WITH THIS
EFFORT CALIFORNIANS REALLY
TAKING THE LEAD.
IN DEVELOPING THESE ONE STOP
SHOP MODELS THAT LINK EARLY
MENTAL HEALTH CARE WITH PRIMARY
CARE SUPPORT EDUCATION
EMPLOYMENT.
PEER SUPPORT AND OTHER EARLY
INTERVENTION FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
A WAY THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
ACROSS THE STATE.
CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE THAT
ACCESS TO SERVICE AS A RESULT WE
AND END UP IN CHEN BRING HUGE
COSTS WHEN OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
AND UP IN OUR JUVENILE JUSTICE
PEOPLE HAVE ON RECOGNIZED AN
UNTREATED MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS THAT ARE ON THE COST
BEING BORNE BY THE STATE.
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE END UP IN
EMERGENCY ROOMS FOR DRUG
OVERDOSES SUICIDE ATTEMPTS
ANOTHER SERIOUS MEDICAL ISSUES.
THE HOPE FOR THIS PROGRAM REALLY
IS TO BE ABLE -- TO ADDRESS
THOSE CAUSED BY CREATING EARLY
ACCESS POINTS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
TO COME IN VERY EARLY TO GET
EARLY MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT
ENVIRONMENT.
THAT IS YOUTH DRIVEN AND YOUTH
FRIENDLY TO ENABLE THIS EARLY
INTERVENTION TO TAKE PLACE IN A
WAY THAT IT DOESN'T CURRENTLY
HAPPEN.
AT THIS POINT AT ALL AS YOU KNOW
WE'VE SEEN OTHER COUNTRIES
DEVELOP THIS MODEL -- THEY
CONTINUE TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF SITES BECAUSE THEY'VE SEEN
THE COST BENEFIT OF THESE
SERVICES THROUGH MORE YOUNG
PEOPLE.
STAYING IN SCHOOL NOT DROPPING
OUT BECOMING -- EMPLOYABLE IN
SUCCESSFUL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY RATHER THAN SPENDING
MORE TIME INCARCERATED OR
ANOTHER KINDS OF SYSTEMS.
SO AS A RESULT WE'VE SEEN THIS
MODEL GROWING -- STRICTLY AND
NOW WITH A HUNDRED AND TEN OF
THESE SITES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THE GROWING ACROSS CANADA
IRELAND -- OTHER PLACES AROUND
THE WORLD REALLY BECAUSE OF THE
SUCCESS OF BUILDING THESE EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS ARE HOPE
WOULD BE.
THAT WITH THESE SERVICES BEING
DEVELOPED WE WILL HAVE AN EARLY
PLACE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO STAY
IN SCHOOL BE SUCCESSFUL AND
BECOME.
AND REMAIN PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU. TWENTY
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST W. IN WITH
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
WOULD ECHO WHAT DOCTOR AT ALL
TIME HAS TO SAY -- YOU KNOW IN
IN MY TENURE IN STATE GOVERNMENT
YOU KNOW OFTEN HAVE BEEN ASKED.
HOW WE SHOULD MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT COSTS AND AND AND WHERE
ARE THEIR WAY SO WE CAN IMPROVE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF DOLLARS?
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
SEEN OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AS PART OF OUR LARGEST
COST DRIVERS ARE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE NOT ALIGNED WITH THE NEEDS
OF PEOPLE WERE TRYING TO SERVE.
AS A RESULT OF THAT PEOPLE ARE
BOUNCING BETWEEN SERVICES
THEY'RE STARTING CARE THEY'RE
ENDING THEIR LEAVING CARE.
THIS PROGRAM IS REALLY DESIGNED
TO START WITH THE YOUNG PEOPLE
AND ASK THEM HOW CAN WE DESIGN A
SYSTEM THAT IS REALLY TAILORED
TO YOUR NEEDS.
AND DO IT SO IN A WAY THAT LINKS
CARE ACROSS HEALTH PHYSICAL
HEALTH REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SUBSTANCE USE.
WITH STRONG LINKAGES TO SOCIAL
EDUCATIONAL EMPLOYMENT HOUSING
SUPPORTS THIS REALLY IS AN EX
VERY EXCITING MODEL AGAIN BASED
ON FOUR OFF OF WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE AROUND THE WORLD WE
VISITED PROGRAMS IN CANADA WE'VE
BROUGHT THOSE FOLKS TO
CALIFORNIA THERE'S TREMENDOUS
AND AN INTEREST IN THIS MODEL.
THE COMMISSION IS SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BECAUSE WE SEE THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE TO
INCENTIVIZE THROUGH A
PARTNERSHIP WITH COUNTIES WAYS
IN WHICH WE CAN BREAK DOWN SOME
OF THE SERVICE SILOS.
THAT OFTEN GET IN THE WAY OF
DESIGNING CARE AROUND PEOPLE'S
NEEDS WITH THE INTENT OF BEING
ABLE TO DELIVER CARE EARLY.
IN AN INTEGRATED AND TAILORED
FASHION THAT AS DOCTOR IT'LL
TIME POINTS OUT IS INTENDED TO
REDUCE THOSE THE COST OF THOSE
BAD OUTCOMES THAT THAT OUR
SCHOOL FAILURE THAT OUR JUVENILE
JUSTICE ORCORRECTIONS IN.
INCREMENTS OF INVESTOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT.
AND AGAIN I WOULD HIGHLIGHT
EMPLOYMENT.
THE COMMISSION IS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS AS A STRATEGY
TO REALLY THINK HOLISTICALLY
AROUND THE SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDE YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND I WOULD SAY EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO BEGIN TO DESIGN
CARE BASED ON THE INDIVIDUALS IN
OUR COMMUNITY IN WAYS THAT ARE
COST EFFECTIVE SO WITH THAT WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND WOULD
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JOHN LEVEL CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
AND UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
ADRIN SHELTON STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BLACK
OF NUMBER CAN SUPPORT.
JEAN FELL SENS ARE CROWDED CITY
COLLEGE STUDENT FULLY SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY A MEDI HYATT AND
SUPPORT WE THINK THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DONE DECADES AGO.
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY
SOCIAL WORK AND ALSO ON THE SIDE
OF MY CANCER AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL I THINK WE NEED A ACT.
IT WRITTEN AS IT WORKS THANK YOU
FOR YOU COULD JUST CAN FIND YOUR
COMMENTS TO WHO YOU ARE WHERE
YOU'RE FROM AND YOUR POSITION
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
SHERRI SAGER SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CELL PACKARD CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL STANFORD AND A SENATOR
BELL SAID WERE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT.
HI GOOD I'M MORNING MY NAME IS
ANNELI ASSAULT ON THE USE THAT
WE SPECIALIST FOR THE STANFORD
CENTER FOR YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH.
AND ONE OF MY YOUTH IT WASN'T
ABLE TO BE HERE SO I WOULD LOVE
TO BE ABLE TO JUST READ HER PART.
IS THAT OKAY.
QUICKLY OKAY IT'S THIS IS FROM
PHOEBE SHE SEVENTEEN UP A LOT
THE STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH IS A
MAJOR ISSUE THAT I AND MANY OF
MY PEERS HAVE EXPERIENCE.
ALONG WITH THE COME SHAME
ISOLATION THAT OFTEN TRANSLATES
INTO ADULTHOOD OF SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES ARE NOT PROVIDED.
THIS CAN SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT
YOUR INDIVIDUALS RELATIONSHIP
AND SPEND THEIR GROWTH WITHIN
THAT YOU WERE TRYING TO SORT OF
MAKE IT CONCISE OKAY.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST IF THE
PROBLEM IS NOT ADDRESS WE WILL
NOT BE LETTING WE WILL BE
LETTING DOWN STRONG ADOLESCENTS
WHO HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO CHANGE
THE WORLD.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HE THE END I SUPPORT
THIS AS A YOUTH ADVISER FOR ALL
KIND OF NOT WHICH IS WHAT THE
STANFORD CENTER FOR YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
THANK YOU -- MY NAME IS ALLEY
I'M ALSO ON THE ADVISORY BOARD
AND I SUPPORT THIS.
ROGER BELLY WAS CARS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
STAVING ON THANK WITH SCOTT'S
INTERNATIONAL OF COME FROM A
STRONG LEAD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI COLLEGE YOU BOZO WITH COUNTY
SAYS STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SORRY JUST GOT AN EMAIL MEDI
HIRED FOR THE BLACK LAW STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION FOR LINCOLN LAW
SCHOOL HERE IN SACRAMENTO ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION FINANCE NO
FILE NO FILE.
MISTER BELL THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE JERRY BROWN I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT WHEN -- SUSPENSE IS
LIFTED THANK YOU THANK YOU JUST
A PERSONAL COMMENT MISTER BELL I
DON'T THINK THERE'S BEEN A
STRONGER CHAMPION ON THE LAST.
FIFTEEN YEARS FOR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THEN YOU AND YOU CONTINUE
TO AMAZE AND IMPRESS ME SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ADVOCACY -- WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWELVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AND THEN YOU'RE GOING
TO PRESENT SB.
ONE NINETY SEVEN MISTER SHERMAN --
UNHAPPY WHICH IS -- DO PASS.
I'M HAPPY 2% SP ONE ONE NINETY
SEVEN THIS BILL IN THE SUNSET ON
THE PROHIBITION ON CALTRANS.
FROM WITHHOLDING RETENTION
PROCEEDS FROM ITS CONTRACTORS --
PRETENSIONS -- HAVE DETRIMENTAL
EFFECTS ON THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY WITH FORCING
CONTRACTORS. TO COMPLETE WORK
WITHOUT FULL PAYMENT FORCING
THEM TO SELF FINANCE PUBLIC
PROJECTS.
THIS DRIVES UP COSTS MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS RESULTS IN.
OUR OUR BIDS GOING UP AND IF
THIS BILL PASSES I ASSUME IT
WOULD HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT ON
THE BIDS WE RECEIVE FOR PROJECTS
ARE RICH AND I BOTH THANK YOU.
THIS IS AN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR.
OF MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF
UNITED CONTRACTORS THE SPONSORS
OF SB.
ONE NINE SEVEN AT THE
PROHIBITION ON RETENTION OFTEN
GOES UNNOTICED BUT HAS EXTREMELY
POSITIVE IMPACTS.
ON SMALL EMERGING CONSTRUCTION
BUSINESSES IT ALLOWS CONTRACTORS
RETAIN CASH FLOW INTO CONTINUE
TO BID ON SUBSEQUENT
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS WITHOUT
LINES OF CREDIT WHICH A ROLL
ALTERNATELY ROLLED INTO THAT THE
COST OF A PROJECT OR HAVING TO
OPERATE ON AND UNCERTAIN
FINANCIAL FOOTINGS.
THIS PREVENTS DELAYS IN
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS IN THE
RESULTING UNNECESSARY COSTS TO
TAXPAYERS. ONE NINE SEVEN SB ONE
NINE SEVEN WILL ENSURE THAT
CALTRANS HAS UNIFORM CONTRACT
PAYMENT SYSTEM BENEFITING BOTH
CONTRACTORS AND THE STATE IN
TERMS OF TIME AND COST SAVINGS.
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE URGE AND
I VOTE THANK YOU.
YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
TAUGHT BLOOM STEIN FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THIRTY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SHEEN NO OPPOSITION A FINANCE
FINANCES NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE
A CALTRANS EXPECTS TO CONTINUE
TO REALIZE MINOR COST SAVINGS
ANNUALLY BY PERMANENTLY
EXTENDING THIS CURRENT PRACTICE
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS FOR MISTER BALLOT
TO DO PASS.
SINGLE.
WE HAVE A MOTION MISTER BALLOTS
LIKE TO CLOSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO LET'S.
GET IT GOING AND SAVE SOME MONEY
URGENT ABOUT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER WELL WE HAVE A MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES I BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY WE CASKEY AYE.
YOUR BILL IS OUT WE HAVE ONE
VACANCY SO THAT'S EVERYBODY.
OKAY -- WE WILL GO TO MISTER
MCGUIRE SINCE IT'S A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION SB.
SIX TWO SIX TWO ON COMMERCIAL
FISHING THANK YOU MISTER MCGUIRE
GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS HOPE
EVERYONE HAD A GOOD WEEKEND THE
JOINT COMMITTEES AND FISHERIES
AND AQUACULTURE ADVANCES ON THIS
BILL ABOUT EVERY COUPLE YEARS SB
TWO SIXTY TWO AIMS TO PREVENT
LONG TERM FISCAL ISSUES.
BY INDEXING COMMERCIAL LANDING
FEES OFF OF THE STANDARD PROGRAM
FOR THE US DEPARTMENT OF
COMMERCE.
IT ALSO EXTENDS TO SUNSET DATE
O THE CHAIRS FAVORITE FISH THE
SEA CUCUMBER PERMIT PROGRAM --
IN THE CURRENT SINCE THAT DATE
IS APRIL FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NEITHER SAY HOW DID YOU KNOW
THAT WAS MY DAY THAT'S ROSA HIGH
DAY.
ARCHER IS RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT
EXACTLY AND I HAVE YOUR WIT WITH
ME.
ROB HOW CRISIS.
AND FEW VERY QUICK SUPPORT OF
WORDS.
PROGRESS CALIFORNIA FISHERIES
AND SEAFOOD INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THAT'S MY FAVORITE
TESTIMONY SO FAR.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION DARE TO CROSS THE
SEA CUCUMBER. ONE FINANCE
FINANCE DOESN'T HAVE A POSITION
ON THIS BILL -- BUT WE KNOW THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE ESTIMATES AN INCREASE
OF FORTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AND REVENUES TO THE
FISHING GAME PRESERVATION FUN.
IF THE EXISTING LANDING FEE
RATES ARE INDEX BASED ON THE
IMPLICIT PRICE DEFLATOR OTHER
DEPARTMENT ALSO ESTIMATES THERE
WILL BE NO NEW COSTS AS A RESULT
OF EXTENDING THE SEA CUCUMBER
FISHERY PERMISSIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MISTER MCGUIRE.
YOU MADE A MOTION MISTER HILL.
YES WE HAVE A MOTION MISTER WIRE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES FOR
A VOTE THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
BARTON TINO AYE BATES.
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL I JONES.
JONES NO WE CAL SKI.
THE CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
MCGUIRE.
MR NIELSEN I SEE OR HEAR.
PLEASE COME UP AND PRESENT.
AN SP TWO EIGHTY SEVEN THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THAT WERE
HAPPY TO HEAR YOUR TESTIMONY SIR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL.
BRINGS SOME CLARITY TO THE
COMMISSION STATE MANDATES
PROCESS IT'S BEEN A PLACE FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS.
IT REQUIRES A TEST CLAIMS
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMISSION AND
STATE MANDATES TO BE SUBMITTED
THE FOLLOWING THE FISCAL YEAR
TIMELINE RATHER THAN THE
CALENDAR YEAR TIMELINE.
AS A THERE'S A DISCLAIMER HE AND
THAT.
A PROCESS AND WE NEED TO GET
THAT STRAIGHTENED OUT THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE
PARTICULARLY AFFECTED BY THIS
AND HENCE THEIR THEIR SUPPORT
AND THEY HAVE BROUGHT THIS TO
OUR ATTENTION [inaudible]
THE THE ISSUE IS THAT THESE
CLAIMS ARE OUT OF COMPLIANCE AND
WE NEED TO BRING THEM INTO
PLANTS THE COST INCURRED HERE
ARE FOR THE CHANGING OF THE
REGULATIONS.
AND WE WOULD REDUCE CHANGE THE
GOVERNMENT CODE TO READ FOR
PURPOSES OF CLAIMING BASED ON
THE DATE OF FIRST AND CURRENT
COST FIRST INCURRING.
THE COSTS THAT MEETING THE
AGENCY THAT'S CLAIMING.
WITHIN TWELVE MONTHS MEANS JUNE
THIRTIETH OF THE FISCAL YEAR
FOLLOWING THE FISCAL YEAR WIND
WHICH THE INCREASED COST WERE
FIRST ENTERED BY THE CLAIMANT
NOW THAT SOME.
CONFUSING TECHNICAL LEGAL
LANGUAGE BUT THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
REQUIRED TO CLARIFY IT.
AND THE THIS BILL WILL NOT LET
NOW LIVE THE LOCAL AGENCIES AND
THE BUDGET IN THE BUDGET AND
THEIR BUDGETING AND THEN THERE.
ASSESSING AND APPLYING FOR THEIR
CLAIMS. TO HAVE THE CLARITY TO
KNOW WHEN. TO PROFFER AND THEN
HAVE THOSE CLAIMS PROCESS.
IT'S FAIRLY TECHNICAL BUT VERY
SIGNIFICANT TO THESE MANY
DISTRICTS AND I'M JUST ASKING
YOU TO FIND THIS FAVORABLY
MISTER DILLON GIVENS OF THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IS HERE TO COMMENT.
DOES YOUR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DEALING GIVEN FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION -- AS A SENATOR SAID
THIS IS BEEN THE PRACTICE FOR
THE LAST THIRTEEN YEARS.
FOR SUBMISSIONS TO THE
COMMISSION ON STATE MANDATES TO
TRACK WITH THE FISCAL YEAR
RATHER THAN THE CALENDAR YEAR --
JUST LAST APRIL THE REGULATIONS
WERE CHANGED BY THE COMMISSION --
TO SIMPLY ALIGN WITH THE
GOVERNMENT CODE WHICH WAS SILENT
ON THE TOPIC -- THIS BILL AS FAR
AS FISCAL COSTS WOULD.
IS ONLY RELATED TO THE UPDATE OF
THE REGULATIONS -- THERE ARE NO
NEW MANDATES INCLUDED IN THIS
BILL -- ANY ADDITIONAL COSTS TO
RESULT FROM -- ADDITIONAL
MANDATES ARE APPROVED -- THE
RESULT OF OTHER BILLS THAT
LEGISLATION IS THAT IS SIGNED
AND SENT AND THEN THE COMMISSION
WITH -- WHO ROOM YEAH CONTINUES
TO RETAIN FULL AUTHORITY TO
APPROVE OR DENY -- CLAIMS -- CAN
APPROVE THOSE OR DENY THOSE THIS
IS SIMPLY THE TIMELINE BY WHICH
WE SUBMIT THOSE CLAIMS.
THE CHANGE THAT WAS MADE LAST
YEAR IN THE REGULATIONS
ESSENTIALLY SHORTENED OUR OUR
CLAIM OUR TIME TO TO SUBMIT THE
CLAIM BY SIX MONTHS.
THIS JUST PUTS IT BACK TO
EXACTLY WHAT IT WAS TAKES A
LANGUAGE THAT WAS IN THE
REGULATIONS AND NOW PUTS IT IN
THE GOVERNMENT CODE.
AND THAT IS THE ONLY CHANGE AND
THERE WAS THE ONLY COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL AGAIN
IN THE ANALYSIS IS EIGHT POINTS
OUT THAT THERE'S A POTENTIAL.
INCREASE -- COST TO THE STATE
AND APPROVED CLAIMS BUT AGAIN
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE NOT RELATED
TO THIS BILL THOSE ARE FOR BILLS
THAT HAVE POTENTIAL MANDATES AND
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
JEFF KNEW WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF RETURNING TO
THE LONG STANDING COMMONSENSICAL --
PREVIOUS REGULATIONS.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE FINANCE THE FILE NO
FILE.
ANY QUESTIONS FOR MISTER NIELSEN
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE --
MISSION IS SOMEONE'S LIKE
CLOTHES THESE ARE INADVERTENT
SEES THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
BUT WE'RE BEST SERVE TO GET OF
CORRECTED SOONER THAN LATER AT
WHAT ASKED FOR A REAL
CONSIDERATION ON SUSPENSE.
THANK YOU ARE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB TWO EIGHTY SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
MR MINING I SEE IS HERE. TO
PRESENT SB THREE FORTY SEVEN AND
AGAIN THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE.
TELL US ABOUT THREE FORTY SEVEN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS IN.
THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR SUSPENSE.
INDULGE THE COMMITTEE -- I DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF WITNESSES I
WILL BE VERY BRIEF.
BUT WE ARE HERE AGAIN TODAY.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA REMAINS IN
CRISIS THE CRISIS THAT IS
IMPACTED EACH AND EVERYONE OF
OUR DISTRICTS AND THAT IS SHOWN
NO SIGN OF RELENTING.
THE EPIDEMIC OF SKYROCKETING
RATES OF OBESITY IN PREVENTABLE
TYPE TWO DIABETES CONTINUES TO
WREAK HAVOC ON THE HEALTH AND
HAPPINESS OF OUR CONSTITUENTS.
IN BURDENS OUR STATE WITH
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
HEALTHCARE COSTS RELATED TO THE
TREATMENT OF THESE PREVENTABLE
CHRONIC DISEASES.
OVER THE LAST DECADE AN
AVALANCHE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
RESEARCH HAS DEFINITIVELY
CONCLUDED THAT THE MAIN DRIVER
BEHIND THE GROWTH OF THESE
PREVENTABLE HEALTH CONDITIONS IN
CHILDREN.
IS THE INCREASED CONSUMPTION OF
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY SEVEN
WILL EMPOWER CONSUMERS TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT THE
BEVERAGES THEY PURCHASE.
BY REQUIRING A SCIENCE BASED
HEALTH WARNING LABEL TO BE
PLACED ON SUGARY DRINKS THAT ARE
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IT CONTAINS SEVENTY FIVE
CALORIES OR MORE FOR TWELVE
FLUID OUNCES WARNING LABELS ARE
A PROVEN AND EFFECTIVE MEANS OF
INFLUENCING CONSUMER BEHAVIOR.
AND HAVE BEEN USED SUCCESSFULLY
ON TOBACCO AND ALCOHOL PRODUCTS
FOR DECADES.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY SEVEN
WILL PROMOTE INFORMED CONSUMER
CHOICE IN WILL LEAD TO BETTER
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA.
WELL THIS BILL IS HEADED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE TODAY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB THREE FORTY SEVEN AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
IN THE DEFENSE OF OUR CHILDREN'S
HEALTH IN WITH YOUR PERMISSION
MISTER CHAIR WITH BRIEF
TESTIMONY -- I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES -- DOCTOR ANGELO
WILLIAMS DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH NETWORK
AND ABIGAIL RAMIREZ SENIOR
POLICY MANAGER LATINO COALITION
FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA -- GOOD
MORNING CHEN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS AB HERE AMERICA'S THE
STATE -- POLICY SENIOR MANAGER
WITH LATINO COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA AND I AM HERE
TODAY BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IT IT
IS IN THE MIDST OF AN A. B. C.
AND DIABETIC.
EPIDEMIC AND IT DOES UP A
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR --
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADING STATE
AND DEBBIE SAYING NOTICE WITH
55% OF THE POPULATION BEING
DIAGNOSED WITH DIABETES BD'S
UNDIAGNOSED DIABETES AND
PRECURSOR TYPE TWO DIABETES.
THERE'S ALSO OVERWHELMING
SCIENTIFIC DATA THAT SHOWS THAT --
SUGARY DRINKS INCREASE THE RISK
OF SURE OF TYPE TWO DIABETES --
AND THE CONSUMPTION OF MORE THAN
ONE SINGLE A BEVERAGE A DAY CAN
INCREASE THE RATES OF OBESITY BY
55% AND TYPE TWO DIABETES BY 26%.
OF THE INCREASING ECONOMIC
BURDEN OF DIABETES IS TOO LARGE
IN PART TO THE INCREASE RATE AND
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
BEING DIAGNOSED.
EVERY YEAR DIABETES AND PRE
DIABETES BECAUSE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AN ESTIMATED THIRTY
NINE POINT FORTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS FOR CD SERIOUS DIABETES.
IN ADDITION TO NINE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN INDIRECT COSTS FROM
LOST PRODUCTIVITY -- THE
ALARMING RATES OF INCREASE
DIABETES HIGHLIGHTS THE NEEDS TO
FOCUS ON PREVENTATIVE EFFORTS
THAT ALIGN INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
WELL BEING IN THE LONG RUN SB
THREE FOUR SEVEN WILL SAVE
CALIFORNIA MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND CURRENT HEALTH COSTS COSTS
BY.
DIAGNOSIS BY DIABETES DIAGNOSIS
THANK FOR THESE REASONS I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M SORRY I'M SORRY GO AHEAD.
AND THE LAWYERS ME UP BECAUSE I
WAS THINKING YOU WERE GONE THAT
WAY ANY WENT THAT.
MY FAULT ARI DOORS MY APOLOGIES --
ANGELA WILLIAMS W. DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH
NETWORK OBVIOUSLY OUR
ORGANIZATION IS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL -- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INNOVATION MY ON PARTICULARLY
TRICKY ITEMS FOR INSTANCE.
THE CARBON TAX AND GLOBAL
WARMING RIGHT -- FUNDING RELATED
TO THE PARADISE FIRES.
HOW TO DIABETES IS A SIMILAR
EPIDEMIC AS IT RELATES TO
AFRICAN AMERICAN 77% MORE LIKELY
TO CONTRACT AND THEN THE OTHER
MINORITY GROUPS THAT ALREADY
HAVE INCREASED NUMBERS? HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARSRIGHT AT
LEAST ONE PORTION OF THE COST OF
THE BILL THERE ARE OTHER
COMPLICATIONS BUT THESE THE
THINGS THAT IS WHAT UPON YOUR
MIND IS IT GOES TO SUSPENSE.
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR OVER TEN YEARS I ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
WITHIN THOSE TEN YEARS THE
NUMBERS IN TERMS OF THOSE THAT
CONTRACT WITH ABC AFTER AMERICAN
COMMUNITY WILL HAVE QUADRUPLED.
PLEASE LOOK AT THE INNOVATIVE
TECHNIQUES TO DEFUSE IN THE PAST
FOR INSTANCE THE BLACK INFANT
HEALTH PROGRAM THEIR SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS THERE'S THIRTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
PARTICULAR RELATED TO TRAUMA IF
WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO CREATE
SOME SORT OF INTEGRATED SYSTEM
THAT TACKLES THE SOLDIER
DETERMINES OF HEALTH WITH TYPE
TWO DIABETES AND STRESS AND
pOTHERS IN MIND.
WILL BE SUCCESSFUL WE ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE LINE UP.
MORNINGS ACT RECORD WELL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
STATE CONTEST.
MICHELLE GIVENS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE ANGEL MAD WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES AND WE ARE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HALEY PENNINGTON'S DO NOT TAX
CITY.
ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ANNIKA DUNCAN SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE IN FULL SUPPORT.
PATRICIA BROWN WELL SPACE HEALTH
COUNSELOR.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
MAY HAVE TO GIVE UP THE CHAIR
THANK YOU
.
CHEN MEMBERS MET CERTAIN OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE MEASURE -- AND HAVE BEEN IN
ITS PREVIOUS ITERATIONS -- LAST
YEAR WE WORKED VERY HARD WITH
SENATORMONNING TO GET TO A
POINT WHERE WE COULD -- AGREED
TO DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE AS IT
RELATES TO RESTAURANTS.
AND CHILDREN'S MEALS AND WE DID
THAT AND SO WE ARE SURPRISED TO
BE HERE AGAIN BUT I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT.
THE THE COMPLIANCE FOR THIS IS
VERY DIFFICULT AND THAT'S WHERE
THE COSTS FOR US WILL OME INTO
PLAY BECAUSE THE BILL DOES
REQUIRE THESE POSTINGS IN THE
FOUR WALLS OF A RESTAURANT.
AND OUT OF THE RESTAURANT AT
EVERY POINT OF PURCHASE AND THAT
IS A TERM THAT WE CONTINUE TO
CHASE AS TECHNOLOGY EVOLVES IN
ORDERS ARE DONE STILL OVER THE
PHONE -- VIA YOUR PHONE VIA THE
THIRD PARTY APPS WHICH ARE NOT
OURS THEY ARE INDEPENDENT -- AND
THEN ALL THROUGHOUT THE
RESTAURANT IT CAN VERY DIFFERENT
BETWEEN A FULL SERVICE
RESTAURANT A FAST CASUAL
RESTAURANT OR QUICK SERVE
RESTAURANTS SO. FOR US THE
COMPLIANCE SITUATION IS SORT OF
THIS BIG CASE AND THAT BRINGS IN
THE COSTS FOR US SO I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT POINT FOR YOU
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
A DRILL COOK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSED --
ECHOING THE COMMENTS FROM THE
RESTAURANTS WE ARE POSING PART
BECAUSE THIS WILL INCREASE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE AS WE SEEK TO FIND AT
THE STATE SIX FIND VIOLATIONS
FOR SOMETHING -- FOR THE SCHEME
THAT GENERATES VERY LITTLE
PUBLIC HEALTH VALUE BEYOND THE
INFORMATION THAT'S ALREADY
AVAILABLE AND CLEARER THAN WHAT
THE SCHEME WOULD -- PROVIDE
WHICH IS THE SUGAR AND CLERK
CONTENT THAT IS ALREADY ON
LABELS AT THE BACK OF EVERY --
BEVERAGE BY THE SCHEME THAT THIS
SB THREE FORTY SEVEN WOULD
CREATE LEE SO CONFUSING OUTCOME
MORE ITEMS BUT WITH MORE OVERALL
SUGAR CONTENT MAY RECEIVE NO
WARNING LABEL AT ALL.
WE'RE BEVERAGES WITH ADDED SUGAR --
WILL RECEIVE A WARNING LABEL
EVEN IF THEY HAVE LESS SUGAR
THAN OTHER BEVERAGES.
BALANCING OUT THESE COSTS OF
ENFORCEMENT -- FOR THIS SCHEME --
IN THIS RELATIVELY LOW BENEFIT
WITH THE OVERALL IMPACT TO THE
THE ECONOMY IS WHAT WE'RE ASKING
YOU TO DO.
AS YOU CONSIDER THIS BILL --
DURING SUSPENSE ARE AS
ASSISTANCE CANDIDATE -- THIS
BILL IN ITS SCHEME WILL DECREASE
A MANUFACTURING JOBS AND
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA AND SO
WE ASK YOU TO CONSIDER THE LOSS
REVENUE MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
IMPACT ON COMMUNITIES -- THAT
THIS BILL WILL HAVE WHEN
MANUFACTURING FACILITY THERE
SHRINK PRODUCTION OR GO AWAY
ENTIRELY THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
GREG HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE CAN
MANUFACTURES INSTITUTE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FEELS INCONVENIENCE
ALLIANCE ALSO POST.
VALERIE NARROW OR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
SUPPOSED.
IN THREE MILLION ON BEHALF OF
THE GROCERY MANUFACTURERS%
ASSOCIATION THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
IN GROW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRACTION SOME PARKS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OTHER LINE UP OF
FINANCE.
NO FILE FILE STORE CASH YOU HAVE
A QUESTION THE OPERATOR ON THE
ANALYSIS AND IN THE REPORT I
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM FINANCE
WEEK WHEN THIS MATTER COMES BACK
BECAUSE IT'S ON SUSPENSE.
IS AT THE THE REPORT ASK.
FOR ONE PERSON ONE ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENTISTS TO SHIP TO ENFORCE
THE SINCE THIS ENTIRE LAW
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AN ANALYSIS GOES
THROUGH THAT.
TYPICALLY ACOSTA 1-000-300-7541
INSPECTION WE'RE CALCULATING
THAT ONE PERSON'S GONNA DO ONE
INSPECTION IN A TEN HOUR PERIOD.
SO I GOT ISSUES WITH THAT IF
THAT'S REASONABLE -- IF THAT
WITH THE TO PUT MY BIGGER
QUESTION IS THAT.
ASSUMING THAT THIS BECAME LAW
FOR THE FISCAL IMPACT BECAUSE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S THE
BREAK EVEN POINT HERE.
AT SOME TIME THESE RESTAURANTS
OR THESE VENDING MACHINES OR
WHATEVER THIS IS A GOOD TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE NECESSARY
WARNING IS AND THERE WON'T BE
ANY VIOLATIONS SO I'D LIKE TO
SEE AN ANALYSIS THAT GIVES ME.
A THREE YEAR PERIOD A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD SO I KNOW WHAT THIS IS
BECAUSE IT SEEMS RIDICULOUS THAT
NOBODY WOULD DO ANYTHING IN THIS
ONE PERSON THE STATE CALIFORNIA
LEGAL RUNNING AROUND CITING
FOLKS AT FIVE HUNDRED BUCKS.
A POP [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
MISTER MONEY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSE AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TRANSFERRED FROM.
BOTH SIDES THIS MORNING QUICK
COMMENT ON THE CONCERNS OF THE
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION -- WE DID
ESTABLISH A GOOD WORKING
RELATIONSHIP ON THE CHILDREN'S
MENU -- I BELIEVE THERE'S A
PATHWAY TO MINIMIZING THE IMPACT
ON RETAILERS -- FAST FOOD
RESTAURANT YOU PUT THE LABEL
ONCE ON THE VENDING.
MACHINE AND YOU'VE SATISFIED
YOUR OBLIGATION A SIMILARLY WITH
THE MENU WE THINK THE REAL
TRANSFORMATIONAL BE AT THE
MANUFACTURE LEVEL WHERE.
ALREADY INFORMATION IS PRINTED
ON CANS AND BOTTLES THIS IS WHAT
WILL GIVE PARENTS INFORMS CHOICE.
IN JUST A FINAL COMMENT THERE'S
BEEN SOME RECENT MEDIA REPORTS
THAT CONSUMPTION OF SODAS HAS IN
FACT GONE DOWN DO WE REALLY NEED
THIS.
THE ANSWER IS YES CERTAIN SODUS
PEPSI COKE.
BUYING IS GONE DOWN THOSE
MANUFACTURERS HAVE DIVERSIFIED
THEIR PRODUCTS TO THEIR CREDIT
SOME WITH LOW CALORIE LOW SUGAR.
OTHERS WHAT WE CALL CAMOUFLAGE
STRING SPORTS TEAMS -- ENERGY
DRINKS LOADED WITH SUGAR ON
SCHOOL SITES WERE SO THIS AREN'T
AVAILABLE BUT NOW THESE WE CALL
THEM CAMOUFLAGED -- LOADED WITH
SUGAR THEY ALSO POINT OUT THEIR
SUGAR AND OTHER PRODUCTS WHY DO
WE PICK ON SO IT IS.
IT'S NOT WE AS POLITICIANS IS
THE PUBLIC HEALTH COMMUNITY IT
IS CONCLUDED THAT FOR CHILDREN
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE THE LEADING
SOURCE OF BAD CALORIC INTAKE.
IS SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES ARE
THREE PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
AND SAN BENITO MONTEREY COUNTY.
AND SANTA CRUZ COUNTY CONDUCTED
A SURVEY TWO YEARS AGO THEY
FOUND OVER 50% OF MIDDLE SCHOOL
STUDENTS SURVEYED.
HAD NOT HAD A GLASS OF WATER IN
THE PRIOR TWENTY FOUR HOURS BUT
HAD HAD A SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGE.
SO IT'S SCIENCE AND MEDICINE
TELLING US THAT THERE IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH EPIDEMIC WE
REALIZE THIS IS NOT THE SOLUTION.
BUT IT IS AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT
OF THE UNIFIED PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE SO WITH THAT I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THIS
MORNING.
AND WE'LL LOOK FORWARD HOPEFULLY
TEACHER SUPPORT IN MOVING THIS
OFF SUSPENSE FOR THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS RUNNING --
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND PASSION
WITHOUT OBJECTIONS SB THREE FOUR
SEVEN WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SO WE HAVE NO MORE AUTHOR CHAU
GO BACK TO THE TOP.
RIGHT.
AND WE'LL START YEAH WILL RUN
THROUGH SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO SB.
EIGHT BY MISTER GLAZER WHOSE WAY
PRESENTATION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE. TOO TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF
SB EIGHT ON STATE PARKS AND
BEACHES [inaudible]
ANYBODY OPPOSED.
SING NOBODY FOR OR AGAINST SB
EIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT
WILL GO OUT.
I'M SORRY FINANCE.
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL I KNEW THAT HOWEVER OF
PARKS AND RECREATION ESTIMATES
WILL INCUR ADDITIONAL COSTS OF
UP TO ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
SPECIAL FUNDS. TO PAY FOR THE
PURCHASE AND INSTALLATION OF
SIGNAGE -- THIS BILL MAY
GENERATE UNKNOWN BUT LIKELY
MINOR REVENUES TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AS PARKS GENERALLY
RECEIVED NO REVENUES FROM
CITATIONS OF THIS NATURE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU -- SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT SERVE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB TWO SIXTY FOUR ALSO BY MR
GLAZER ON WINE GROWERS TASTING
ROOMS TWENTY ONE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
FINANCE YOUR FILE NO FILE SEEING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB TWO SIX FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
WE'VE DISPENSED WITH MR BELL'S
BILLS WILL GO TO MISTER DODD SB
NINETEEN ON WATER RESOURCES.
AS OR ANYONE HERE IN FAVOR OF SB.
NINETEEN ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB -- NINETEEN
SEEING NO ONE OR FOR YOU COMING
UP FOR SB NINETEEN NO.
FINANCE THE FILE.
NO FILE ANY QUESTIONS YOU KNOW
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINETEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB TWENTY BY MISTER DOT ON
SURPLUS STATE PROPERTY.
A RELATED TO NAPA COUNTY HIS OR
ANYONE IN FAVOR.
OF SB TWENTY ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB.
TWENTY SEEING NO RUSH TO THE
MICROPHONE FINANCE THE FILE NO
FILE ANY QUESTIONS SEEING NO
QUESTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWENTY WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB TWENTY TWO BY MS LABEL ON
RAPE KIT TESTING IS THERE ANYONE
IN FAVOR OF SB.
TWENTY TWO ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NEITHER WILL GO TO
FINANCE YOUR FILE NO FILE ANY
QUESTIONS SEEING NO QUESTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWENTY TWO
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE -- MISLI WAS
ALSO WEIGHED PRESENTATION ON SB
TWO SIX SIX ON CALPERS BENEFIT
ADJUSTMENTS. TWENTY ONE IN FAVOR.
ANYONE OPPOSED FINANCE ARE FILE
BE TWO SIX SIX NO FILE -- FILE
SEEING NO RUSH OF HANDS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB.
TWO SIX SIX WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
SB TWENTY THREE BY MR WIENER ON
UNLAWFUL ENTRY OF A VEHICLE. TO
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB.
TWENTY THREE SEEING NO ONE
FINANCING FILE NO FINAL SEEING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB.
TWENTY THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
SB THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR CHIANG
ON CALIFORNIA ACTS TASK FORCE SO
ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
FINANCE THE FILE NO FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THIRTY FIVE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MS ATKINS IS
WAIVED PRESENTATION ON SB FIFTY
TWO ON CAL GRANT SEE AWARDS IS
THERE ANYONE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
MISS ATKINS.
SB FIFTY TO ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE [inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE FINANCE ON
SB FIFTY TWO NO FILE NO FILE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIFTY TWO WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE.
SB SIXTY SIX MS ATKINS ON MEDI
CAL THIRTY ONE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION IS
THERE OF THE FILE NO FILE SEEING
NO QUESTIONS SB.
SIXTY SIX WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE.
WE WILL SKIP OVER MR WELTE
MOMENTARILY AND GO TO SB FIFTY
SIX BY MISTER ROTH.
UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
IS OR ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE HERE OPPOSITION FINANCE
WE DO NOT HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION ON THIS BUT WOULD NOTE
THAT THE BILL APPROPRIATES ONE
HUNDRED FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND IN. TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION OF WHICH IS ON GOING TO
EXPAND THE UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- WITHOUT ANY
QUESTIONS -- THAT BILL WILL GO
TO CSUS PANTS FROM MISTER ROGERS
BE.
FIFTY SIX I SEE MR WILK HERE.
MISTER WELCOME HE WOULD COME UP
AND TELL US ABOUT SB.
FIFTY THREE WHICH IS. EIGHT TO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
BUT TO CALL THIS THE PORTANTINO
WILL BILL [inaudible] FIVE
ANYWAY ME STRUCTURE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB FIFTY
THREE WHICH FXES A LOOPHOLE IN
THE BAGLEY KEENE OPEN MEETINGS
ACT. TWO TO ENSURE COMPLETE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FROM STATE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS STATE
AGENCIES BOARDS AND OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL BODIES TO FORM
ADVISORY SUBCOMMITTEES.
THEY DO NOT HAVE TO COMPLY WITH
THE OPEN MEETING REQUIREMENTS SO
LONG AS THEY ONLY HAVE TWO
MEMBERS THE SICK COMMITTEES ARE
CAPABLE OF BUILDING SIGNIFICANT.
POWER AND INFLUENCE BUT ARE ABLE
TO CLOSE TO MEETINGS UP TO THE
PUBLIC BECAUSE OF A TECHNICALITY
IN THE CURRENT LAW.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES JUST TAKE
THE PROFESSION THAT WAS PASSED
IN?
NINETEEN NINETY THREE IN THE
ROUGH AND BROWN ACT THAT WEEK A
CAB COMPEL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
DO.
AND PUT THAT SAME PROVISION IN
SO WE TREAT OUR STATE AGENCIES.
AS FAIRLY AS WE TREAT OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
SO THE INFORMATION THIS BILL MAY
IMPOSE MINOR TO MODERATE COST
FOR CERTAIN STATE ENTITIES.
BUT THOSE STATE AGENCIES
AGENCIES SHOULD ONLY BE AFFECTED
IF THEY ARE CURRENTLY EXPLOITING
THE LOOPHOLE IN EXISTING LAW.
SO SB FIFTY THREE WASHER OPEN
AND ACCOUNTABLE STATE GOVERNMENT
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
DO YOU HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WE FOUND OUT A FIVE PM ON FRIDAY
THAT WE ARE DOING THIS BILL SO
NOW.
OKAY IS THERE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE ONE NO.
SORT OF I HAVEN'T BEEN STAFFING
THIS BILL SO -- I JUST TOOK OVER
FOR THE PERSON WHO'S ON LEAVE --
I UNDERSTAND WE HAD SOME
CONCERNS WE TALKED ABOUT IT OF
THE ADVISORY BOARD AS FAR AS I
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE DECISION
MAKING POWERS WERE AFRAID THAT
THIS MIGHT RESULT IN GOVERNMENT
WASTE -- BY HAVING TO HAVE OPEN
MEETINGS AND SCHEDULED MEETINGS
JUST TO TALK ABOUT THINGS THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY MAKE DECISIONS
ON SO I KNOW THAT'S ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE -- SOME
MEMBERS ON OUR BOARD LIKE THE
IDEA OF MAKING MORE TRANSPARENCY --
SO THE REASON WE'RE STILL IN
OPPOSITION IS BECAUSE WE
ACTUALLY SUPPORTED A PRIOR
VERSION WHICH HAD MORE EXPLICIT
LANGUAGE.
WERE FREE THAT THE CURRENT
VERSION MIGHT RESULT IN -- MIGHT
BE TOO VAGUE AND SO WE ACTUALLY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE EXPLICIT
LANGUAGE ADDED BACK IN FROM
PRIOR BILLS -- SO FOR THAT
REASON WERE IN OPPOSITION -- BUT
WE CAN TALK WE CAN FIGURE OUT
WHY. ONE SECOND YOU DID NOT
IDENTIFY WEEK HI I AM SO SORRY --
MEDI HIGHER CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY.
MR WORK WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND -- FIRST TIME I'M
HEARING THIS -- FRANK THOMPSON
IS SEPARATING THE BILL ON OUR
STAFF SO -- PLEASE GET TOGETHER
WITH HIM.
THANK YOU SING NO THEIR
OPPOSITION FINANCE NO FILE NO
FILE ANY QUESTIONS.
MR WHY COUNTY COURT -- THE
OPPOSITION RAISES A GOOD POINT
BECAUSE THERE'S NO ACTION THAT
THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
WHAT THE TRIGGER HERE IS JUST
THE USE OF STATE FUNDS SO?
WHAT OTHER I GUESS OCT TOP TYPE
OF ACTIVITY WOULD REQUIRE WOULD
KICK -- ECKLEY KILLEEN THIS IS
NOT A WIDESPREAD PRACTICE BUT IT
IS A PRACTICE THIS FIRST CAME.
TO MY ATTENTION WITH SOMEBODY HE
WANTED TO DEBT TO TO ATTEND A
STANDING COMMITTEE OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
AND THEY WENT TO THE COMMITTEE
AND THEY WERE BARRED FROM THEY
ARE BARRED FROM ENTERING IT.
AND WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE PUBLIC THE LARGEST PUBLIC --
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT IN THE
HISTORY OF MANKIND I THINK YOU
DESERVE TO HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND AND TRANSPARENCY THERE'S A
FEW OTHER AGENCIES TO DO THIS TO
BE HONEST WITH YOU IT'S VERY FEW.
AND SO I THINK MOST PEOPLE -- LE
ALLOW OPENING OPENING IT UP I
KNOW MY OWN COMMUNICATIONS TRICK
THAT I WE USED TO BE ON THE
BOARD OF THEY JUST GOT CITED FOR
OUR BROWN ACT VIOLATION BECAUSE
THEY WERE NOT THEY WERE BORING
MEMBERS FROM THE PUBLIC. TO THE
STANDING COULD TEST AND
COMMITTEE NAY WERE CITED.
BUT SO THAT WE HAVE THAT THE
LOCAL LEVEL BUT WE DON'T HAVE IT
UP HERE.
I GUESS MISTER CHAIR THE THE
QUESTION IS IS THAT THAT
COMMITTEE TAKES NO ACTION IT'S
THE WHOLE COMMITTEE EVEN IF
PEOPLE ARE BARRED FROM THIS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
IT'S THAT MATTER COMES BACK TO
THE FULL BODY THAT BODY HAS AN
OPEN TRANSPARENT HEARING THEY
HEAR FROM THE VISOR COMMITTEE
PERSON THEY COME IN WITH THE
REPORT.
THE PUBLIC.
I'M I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE IS THE HARM TO THE PUBLIC
IF THEY COME IN AT THAT TIME AND
SAY WE DISAGREE WITH THAT -- I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND NO SIR I CERTAINLY
SACKED ACCESS TO INFORMATION
RIGHT IF THEY'RE HAVING STANDING
COMMITTEES AND THEY'RE HAVING A
YEAH THEY'RE NOT TAKING BOTH
WITH THEIR CERTAINLY HAVING DOES
DISCUSSIONS.
THE GETTING INPUT FROM STAFF AND
AND OTHERS SO I I DON'T SEE THE
HARM OF THE PUBLIC BEING FULLY
INFORMED ON WHATEVER THE
PARTICULAR ISSUE AS WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT SCHEDULED MEETINGS
SO OFTEN TIMES REGULARLY
SCHEDULED MEETINGS.
AND AS YOU KNOW A LOT OF TIMES
ADVISORY COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATIONS THEN BECOME PRO
FORMA ACTIONS OF THE NEXT.
BODY AND SO I DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM AND THE COST IS ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
ESTIMATE.
THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT PER YEAR.
SOMEBODY SAID THAT IN THIS
REPORT.
ON PAGE ONE OF LESS THAN.
OKAY LESS THAN [inaudible]
LAST.
MISTER CHAIR IF I COULD JUST.
GO AHEAD MR HELP ME IT JUST
SEEMS THAT IT'S IT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THERE ARE THOSE WHO WILL
BE INFLUENCE IN HAT ADVISORY
BOARD AND THEY WILL HAVE ACCESS
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE PUBLIC TO SEE THAT AND TO
KNOW THAT GENTRAN TO A MOVIE
HAVING TO MOVE.
THE BILL WE HAVE A MOTION -- ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
WHICH WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I THINK THE GREATER THE
TRANSPARENCY THE GREAT
ACCOUNTABILITY ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION --
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
WITH SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES.
AND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PATH TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO EYEING
FORTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL I JONES.
JONES I WE CAL SKI [inaudible]
I WE COUNTY I YOUR BILL IS OUT.
SIX ZERO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL MOVE ON TO SB.
ONE FIVE FOUR BY DR PAN WHICH
SHE IS WAY PRESENTATION IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE.
ANYONE HERE.
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF ONE FIVE
FOUR SEEING NO ONE IN FAVOR
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NOBODY ON EITHER SIDE AS
FINANCE HAVE A REPORT ON SB ONE
FIVE FOUR NO NO FILE NO FILE ANY
QUESTIONS NO QUESTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ONE FIVE
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB ONE EIGHTY FOUR BY MISTER
MOORE LOCK ON JUDGES DEFERRED
RETIREMENT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE.
ANYONE HERE IN FAVOR OF MISTER
MOORE Là ACCESS BE.
ONE EIGHTY FOR ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
FINANCE NO FILE NO FILE SEEING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB.
ONE EIGHTY FOUR WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
WE HAVE MISTER HILLS.
WAVE PRESENTATION ON SB TWO
NINETY FOUR PROPERTY TAXATION IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE HERE OPPOSITION GENESIS
WE COULD DO IT.
DO OF NEGATIVE RECOMMENDATION
YES -- BUT TO SEE NOBODY IN
FAVOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FINANCE HELP FILE NO FILE SEEING
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SB TWO NINE FOUR WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE -- SB THREE OH TWO BY
YOURS TRULY -- IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE ON GOBIZ ON THE
REPUBLICAN OUR MEDIA TRADE
OFFICE THAT IS A CANDIDATE FOR
SUSPENSE I SEE NO ONE IN.
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION A SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB.
THREE OH TWO BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE --
OFFERS AT THE NEXT ONE LATE AT
THE END.
WE WILL MOVE ON TO MISTER
ARCHULETA HAS WAY PRESENTATION
ON HIS TWO BILLS.
SB THREE SIX EIGHT ON PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICERS.
SEEING NO ONE IN FAVOR NO
OPPOSITION IS THERE A FILE ON SB
THREE SIXTY EIGHT THE FILE.
NO FIVE FOR DASHER FOR FILE ON
MINE.
NO FILE EITHER ALL RIGHT.
YES SIR.
COME ON UP.
NO NO YOU CAN DO RIGHT THERE
[inaudible]
YEP.
JUST IDENTIFY WE GET MAD THAT HE
HIRED CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY -- WE ARE ACTUALLY AN
OPPOSITION TO A SIMILAR BILL IN
THE ASSEMBLY THAT'S EXPANDING.
THE UP OVER PROTECTIONS AND WE
FEEL THAT -- THIS BILL I MEAN
I'M I'M TRYING TO GET A POLICY
ARE GONNA BUT WE ARE ENOUGH
OPPOSITION SO THAT'S ALL YOU
NEED TO KNOW.
THANK YOU.
PATRICIA BROWN WELL SPACE HEALTH
COUNSELOR I OPPOSE.
SO WE HAVE OPPOSITION TO MR
ARCHER LETTERS SB -- THREE SIXTY
EIGHT FILE.
NO FILE NO FILE -- WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB.
THREE SIXTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB FIVE SEVENTEEN ALSO
BY MR ARCHER LEAD ON THE DMV --
RECORDS AND CONFIDENTIALITY IS
THERE ANYONE HERE.
MR LEVEL.
YES -- MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- JOHN LEVEL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC PARKING
ASSOCIATION.
AND SEVERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
GROUPS ALSO IN SUPPORT -- WE ARE
PUZZLED.
AS TO WHY THIS BILL WAS PUT ON
THE SUSPENSE FILE.
BECAUSE THE BILL IN.
ITS OWN BODY HAS A MECHANISM TO
COVER.
ANY ADDITIONAL SORT OF PASS
SPECIFICALLY.
SB.
FIVE SEVENTEEN PROVIDES THAT
ANYONE WHO WOULD BENEFIT FROM
THIS BILL CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS OR PARKING CONTROL
OFFICERS.
RUBRIC OF -- THE DMV PROTECTIONS
WOULD HAVE TO PAY A FEE FOR THE
APPLICATION THAT THEY MUST FILE
WHICH FEE IS AIMED AT COVERING
THE COSTS.
IN THE COSTS OF THE BILL -- THAT
SAID -- WE WILL STRONGLY
ADVOCATE THAT THIS BILL BE
REMOVED FROM SUSPENSE AND MOVED
ON WHEN THOSE ISSUES COME BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVEL ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
ON SB FIVE SEVENTEEN FINANCE THE
FILE NO FILE ANY QUESTIONS.
THE ANALYSIS THOSE OUTLINED COST
CONCERNS SO THANK YOU.
FOR SHARING YOUR OPINION WILL.
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION AS IT
SITS ON SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIVE SEVENTEEN WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
WE HAVE SB FOUR SIXTEEN BY MR
HUESO ON EMPLOYMENT WORKERS
COMPENSATION -- ANYONE IN
SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IS THERE A
FILE.
FILE NO FILE ANY QUESTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FOUR
SIXTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPEND SO I
THINK THAT LEAVES EVERYTHING BUT
THE CLAIMS FELL RIGHT.
BATES FOR JEWS TAKE OVER AS
NINE
THANK YOU A BUT A VICE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- SB FOURTEEN
FOR EIGHTEEN IS ONE OF THE
BILL'S CARRIED BY THE CHAIRS OF
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES.
EACH YEAR TO PROVIDE
APPROPRIATION SRT FOR LEGAL
SETTLEMENTS APPROVED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THIS URGENCY BILL APPROPRIATES
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
DO J.. FOR THE PAYMENT OF THE
FOLLOWING CLAIMS AGAINST THE
STATE -- ROBERT M. MILANO --
VERSE JOHN CHUNG AND AL JERRY BE
APPS TEAM AT ALBERS ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER AT AL.
SUBROGATION CLAIMS BY THIRTY
EIGHT INSURANCE COMPANIES
RELATED TO THE SCAN FILE AND
FORTY FIVE INDIVIDUALS.
GOVERNMENT CLAIMS FOR DAMAGES AS
A RESULT OF THE SCAN FILE -- THE
SETTLEMENTS WERE ENTERED INTO
LAWFULLY BY THE STATE UPON
ADVICE OF COUNSEL AND ARE
BINDING STATE OBLIGATIONS ANY
FUNDS APPROPRIATED.
IN EXCESS OF THE AMOUNTS
REQUIRED FOR THE CLAIMS REVERT
BACK TO THE GENERAL FUND AS
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
I'D LIKE TO OFFER AN AUTHOR'S
AMENDMENT TO SPECIFY.
AN ENCUMBRANCE PERIOD FOR
PAYMENTS RELATED TO MY ON CLAIM
AS REQUESTED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- WITH ME TODAY WE
HAVE FOLKS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CERRADA DEPEND WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THE QUESTIONS FROM GO HERE AND
FINISH MY CASTING UNDER THE MONO --
THE MATTER I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
POOL MONEY INVESTMENT ACCOUNT IS
THE TWO POINT THREE NINE BUT
ONCE THE MATTER GOES INTO.
TRIAL AND YOU'RE IN THE TRIAL
SYSTEM THAT WOULD BE THAT
INTEREST RATE JUICE.
IN ORDINARY TIME BUT ONCE IT
GOES TO TRIAL IN THE COURT OF
APPEAL GIVES IT 10% INTEREST
RATE ON THE DELAY OF PAYMENT.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE'S A
CONFLICT IN THIS.
I GUESS THE QUESTION IS IS CAN
YOU EXPLAIN THAT LOOK AT LEGAL
TO SEE A DISTINCTION THAT
FINANCES MAKING ON THE PAYMENT
IN AND IF IT'S HELD TO BE.
INADEQUATE BY THE COURT OF
APPEALS WE COME BACK AGAIN FOR
THE ADJUSTMENT.
AT THE GAME POND HERE.
THE THE THE THE ISSUE UNLESS WE
DID -- APPEAL IT UP TO THE WE WE
DID APPEAL IT UP TO THE SUPREME
COURT SAID THE COURT OF APPEALS
AFFIRMED IT -- ON JUNE TWENTY
SIX TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THEN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT DENIED
THE PETITION FOR REVIEW ON
OCTOBER.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHTEEN SAYS
THAT'S WHEN -- THE THAT'S WHEN
WE WEEK CAME BACK TO TAKE OUT
THIS INTO THE CLAIMS BILL BUT IN
TERMS OF THE THE BREAK DOWN I
WOULD DEFERRED AT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
YEAH I WOULD CONFIRM WITH DOJ
HAS SAID WE DID A KILL THE 10% A
TO THE SUPREME COURT HOWEVER A
THE COURTS.
HELD OTHERWISE -- WE DO CONTINUE
TO BELIEVE THAT THE P. I. P. M.
I. A RATE -- SHOULD APPLY BOTH
PROSPECTIVELY AND RETROACTIVELY
SO IS THE THIRTY SEVEN POINT ONE
POST JUDGMENT AWARD CALCULATED
ON A 10% STATUTORY RAPE.
YES IT IS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
NEW QUESTIONS OF ARE THERE ANY
ARE IAN.
SUPPORT HERE ANY OPPOSITION.
OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
THINK YOU COMMENTED THAT WE YOU
DO THAT FORMALLY FOR THE RECORD
THANK YOU YES WE SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE WITH THE AMENDMENTS AS
THAT PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU.
MOVE THE BILL.
HAVE A MOTION ON ANY OTHER
COMMENT AND CALL THE ROLL MA'AM
SECRETARY.
WE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
BACK LAST.
SORRY JUMPED THE GUN NOW CAN I
JUST MOVING YOU ALONG THAT'S ALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES JONES I WE CASKEY
HI BECAUSE HE AYE [inaudible]
BILLS OUT.
SO THAT BILLS OUT. ZERO THERE'S
NOTHING.
THERE'S NOTHING ON CALL
EVERYTHING'S BEEN DISPENSED WITH.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
WE WILL DO THIS AGAIN SHORTLY.
AND OFTEN THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED [inaudible]
WE